The backstage was
long ago created for the Ukrainian Cossacks about the
decom field on the left birch the river is a
hideous place of beshachts and fishing for
merchants and grain growers the
deucenter smells like a river and freshness and a little bit of toads Yes
Solovyov
Sam Mr.
after all, the
library And this Sash the library will want to
rule manually rockfest in the center of the
Arab there again the need will still be a park a
park to the river and there a catamaran rental
and I’m cool to anyone you filed se Mister
Biysk Mister military wake-up call from participating
morals instead of talent and people
know his words
our account
boom misplaced the buloday swelled up and the
castle But after all, the walls of garbage will block the
overgrowth aktoria I can’t cinema
delyudenev cute from Mushen Grad I’ll manage
while my souls are in thoughts
and Cola suffocated on a toad, this nightingale
basenodia  day people see off the sun to
Zahid and the villain checks our
a  know we turn about Spain, otherwise
people will turn our people will again become a
criminal and a hero together
and no one on Grata Morola of all Kira niches
to live
Mit After all, we depend on the yakfon for the same burden to
create naveya with the king and again
they will fast and you are so twisted and filed
with mine  place
Starobilsk Ukraine